spesso sentiamo nominare queste classi
bis nei giornali se poi si parla di
energia e tecnologia di informazioni
forse molti hanno chiaro almeno 15 dove
stiamo andando
le società sostenibile l'energia
sostenibile
i prodotti richiedere i libri di forza 5
continua a dimenticare il pas della
ragione c'è la vera sfida del futuro è
quella che ci conosce effettuare una
transizione di questo libro della
sfilata finire quattro argomenti
principali il primo e più importante i
cappelletti che non ci per lottare a
resistere eventi climatici dobbiamo
operare su quello che la medicazione che
non è altro per decarbonizzare il parco
generativo cioè fare in modo più sicuri
l'italia sempre prima fronti non
sostenibile durevole fosse router e
dall'altro risparmiare ovviamente
energia dall'altro adattarsi adattato le
infrastrutture esistenti adesso ad
incrementare gli effetti dei cambiamenti
climatici e stanno indicatori di messina
allo stesso tempo dobbiamo ridurre del
governo delle prime ci sono comparti
oggi produttivi che usavano molto tra la
massa alle materie di vettese
utilizzate il peso del prodotto di 1.500
euro
quindi quando produciamo 1 1499 subito
forse dobbiamo ripensare anche al modo
in cui costruiamo prodotti e servizi
e poi ovviamente c'è un discorso di
migliorare i servizi e lavori cioè fare
in modo che tutte le inefficienze che
causano scontenti non solo disagi agli
utenti ma anche scompensi economici e
sociali dovranno essere localizzati
sotto un substrato di una governance
coeli insieme i regolamenti che
faciliterà questa grandissima e tutto
questo discorso avviene in un non amico
di un'innovazione sociale l'integrazione
sociale perché nessuna rivoluzione
sostenibile ambiente sostenibile se non
è applicabile a tutto alcuni a tutto e
che lì non possiamo parlare di un paese
che ha preso una botta sostenibile senza
una l'inter e quel modello e rispondono
tutti i piani quindi questo è il
contesto all'interno del quale si
sviluppa la smart city ma che cos'è
marsiglia la sua city non è altro che la
riproposizione 500 millenario che cosa
ci ha spinti a socializzare anche i
vicini ci ha spinti la consapevolezza e
la conoscenza del fatto che insieme le
diversità messe insieme lavorando
insieme proteggendoci insieme in un
aggregato perdiamo siamo riusciti ad
ottenere tutto di più della somma di
sicuro questo è quello che ha portato
alla socializzazione
inflazione oggi l'organizzazione un
processo quasi inevitabile che continua
ad aumentare velocità vertiginose
l'obiettivo è di rendere sostenibile
questo processo
allora la mafia non è altro che una rete
organizzata con l'intelligenza di
intelligenza che l'informazione la
lettera dell'informazione ai santissimi
ficcati for national communication
technology cioè tutte quelle tecnologie
che riguardano lo scambio di
informazioni queste informazioni non è
solamente la rete internet tutto quello
che vediamo il musico anche il passaggio
di informazioni che il livello
sottostante come per esempio come stiamo
consumando quanto stiamo consumando
quando il ruolo che forse si tende a
torino gli scettici tendono a perdere
che pensano che l'integrazione di
maggiore tecnologia significa
spersonalizzare la nostra vita in realtà
in quello del signor in età sempre più
importante lo è ancora più importante
all'interno il nose massini
vi faccio un esempio molto classico
quando si parla di energia forse sì
ci sentiamo spesso dire che è importante
che noi costruiamo centrali energie
rinnovabile perché belle fossili sono
sono sostenibili che bisogna ridurre le
dispersioni
si parla tanto di farsi l'impianto in
casa in realtà le tappe sono altre
sezioni napoli grafico se noi pensiamo
che la prima quella dedicata a
un'estrazione è una colonna che vale 100
ed è la mia energia una volta che ho
estratto il petrolio escludiamo le
ragioni che ho speso per stato ma quello
è il quantitativo della gentile che
possono produrre l'energia elettrica che
mi sei arrivato ora nel momento in cui
momento per petrolio il carbone quel gas
del pro centrale generalmente le grosse
centrali e le scelte tecniche non fanno
generazione cioè producono dal calore
ottenuto procurare genetica e il calore
è rimasto lo lasciano in apposterà
oppure in un lago di più quindi
l'efficienza di questa sera
basta che non parte l'energia si perde
del primo processo e quindi ecco che la
mia cacciamo chi e come cercare e poi
successivamente nei passaggi di
trasmissione alta la tensione per ad una
trasformazione e la distribuzione con
trecate si perde con energia e quindi
con la si vede nel voto finale
oggi vi faccio un esempio classi con
formule tipo di vecchia generazione in
una casa dei piccoli un giro e mezzo
oggi lo stesso forno riesce andare con
758 cioè circa metano rendere un
servizio uguale a quello precedente
quindi non abbiamo fatto altro che
ottenere lo stesso servizio con minore
spreco di energia
allora quanto è importante cambiare la
fonte ma sarà rinnovabile quant'è
importante avvicinare l'impianto a causa
delle dure delle dispersioni ma in
realtà è ancora più importante il
francesco nuti cominciare noi a
migliorare questo mondo e lo si fa
cominciando a consumare di meno che si
fanno molto poco di ridurre consumi
finali si vada molto rinnovabili tra la
cosa più importante
guardate se io un giorno fa un piccolo
risparmio
cioè cambio per esempio for metrico il
mio risparmio nella catena risalendo a
monte rappresento risponde molto più
grande oggi è dimostrato che investire
lo stesso quantitativo dell'anno nel
risparmio energetico viene molto rifiuto
investire la stessa coppia di denaro
nella produzione energetica pulita
allora forse è importante come c'è da
pensare che non dobbiamo aspettare che
il mondo cambia intorno ma il mondo poi
ci a cambiare nel momento in cui noi
facciamo minuti a questa è un modello
che poi si applica tante altre cose il
sistema energetico l'escluso la smart
city brani sistemi diversi
la nostra casa diventerà una centrale
energetica non nel senso unicamente di
produzione energetica perché andremo
magari in pista per in congelatore
vedendo i rifiuti
noi andremo a separare dall'acqua in
rifiuto organico cioè il ruvido quello
che noi tutti amici
come tutte le sostanze organiche se
separiamo l'acqua diventa un possibile
invece di farlo raccogliere un'impresa
portarlo trasformate compost e
ridistribuirlo il futuro sarà ancora
meglio
conveniente perché risparmierà maggiore
energia meno utilizzo dei servizi e non
separare l'acqua dalla frazione organica
di utilizzare la frazione organica secca
come un possibile caso come si crea
codice stradale il calore e quindi la
mia casa diventerà una centrale di campo
della reggina e poi potrà essere la mia
auto elettrica ma posso lasciare
parcheggiata nel garage e l'adedy suo
accumulatore di potrà dare energia
quando gli altri apparecchi in casa non
aria squadra viene che sufficienti o
quando il costo dell'energia magari sarà
più conveniente di quella che ha molto
mercato
tutto questo è il panorama della
generazione distribuita in realtà un
unico principato in questo panorama è
riuscita ad abbattere i picchi un'altra
le grosse scrive noi forse non
ragioniamo con tutte le centrali che
abbiamo in italia molto spesso sono
state noi abbiamo una 2 dic c'e un
piccolo mezzogiorno in un piccolo si era
associato questi due picchi che a volte
pure il nostro giorno mi richiedono il
posto dire tante centrali per soddisfare
la richiesta andare in realtà poi un
piccolo progresso del pil
il sistema se non riuscissimo anche in
futuro lo faremo a organizzare una rete
di consumi dove consumo localizzato
diminuisce che innanzitutto tutte le
espressioni e viene fatto in maniera
tale che un sistema di intelligenza di
per universal e da quando è il momento
di consumare di più a quando dico per
fare in modo da distribuire il picco in
tutto l'arco della giornata in questa
maniera il numero di centrali esprime
scende drasticamente e scene soltanto
perché noi abbiamo deciso di modificare
il nostro modello di lo stesso modello
si può applicare la mobilità come fare a
ridurre drasticamente l'impatto della
mobilità bisogna ridurre il numero di
auto che circa una bisogna ridurre il
consumo dell'auto specifica sono
discorsi paralleli il innanzitutto
cominciamo a guardare un attimo cos'è
l'auto ho girato oggi è la stessa auto
che mercedes benz
ben 800 aveva costruito si basa sul
motore a combustione interna
il rendimento è migliorato dei pochi
punti percentuali ma il principale ma lo
stesso sono 150 anni che continuiamo a
produrre auto sulla stessa tecnologia in
realtà molto al presidio molto molto
sbagliato oggi in modo in cui possiamo
lato logica il rapporto che ha il peso
dell'auto che l'effettivo spostamento
alle persone è generalmente per 95 5
quindi ho spento 95 per cento all'anno
energia per spostare l'auto e 5 per
cento lo spostare il passeggero un
baleno il mio vedono servizio per
passeggero quindi forse sarebbe il caso
di cominciare dove erano state l'auto
piuttosto che lavorare a migliorare il
motore progressivamente 17 milioni e
all'aperto avendo soltanto piccoli
miglioramenti di percentuali in questo
modo che fa consumare molto meno
radicalmente meno ma si può parlare
anche di auto elettriche da biblica ma
la cosa più importante in cui c'era
costruire qualcosa che l'insegnamento e
alla stessa maniera a usarne di meno
perché sono settetto moltiplicatore cioè
utilizzare meno auto significa
utilizzare meno meno cromatici inutili
interrotto binari delle strade
finalmente
attenzione a livello grafico meno
impatti sulla salute le cosiddette
esternalità e quindi il car sharing
campoli che oggi già esistono ma che
forse non sono spinti a sufficienza in
futuro saranno governati da questo
sistema di intelligenza e questa
intelligenza originale faremo per dirci
dove stato un intervento congiunto che
può sapere dove l'auto una bicicletta
poi il mattutino decideremo anche la
destinazione e si crea la cosiddetta
intermodalità cioè noi potremmo cambiare
dalle due volte alle 4 dal tram al treno
con un percorso disegnato sui cellulari
e fare in modo di ridurre drasticamente
il numero di mezzi perché io l'auto lo
lascio molto spesso parcheggiata
superata la gran parte del territorio
l'inter rimane parcheggiate lealtà io
penso che siamo artigiano attenutata ad
altre persone
felice una condivisione del servizio
diventa un servizio online
questo modello si ovviamente si
rispecchia anche nella sua acconcia
nella nostra casa la casa e giudica di
acilia motion molte tecnologie permette
intelligente nel senso di farla con
spari di vino esiste isolamento si sono
soluzioni passive architettoniche 20 20
le pareti solari impianti a pavimento
radiante solito sono ormai decine di
altre soluzioni ma tutte queste sono in
realtà quella che la città 2.0 alla casa
della versione 2.0 per essere un po
semplicistici nella classificazione la
casa sarà gestita da un sistema
intelligente che non solo ci dà
l'annuncio deve essere per esempio vi
faccio un esempio fra tanti di
illuminazione dentro la casa sarà
governata da un sensore che sa che ore
sono e che la fine siamo e fare in modo
che di giorno la temperatura del sole
sarà equivalente a quella del sole a
picco e la sera diventerà un certo in
causa perché col tramonto la luce
ivan cambia colore per di normalità più
arancio rosso ma punto l'inter e rossi
quindi questi duemila ciellina mica fare
in modo che quando entriamo dentro casa
noi avremo lo shock romantico era il
nostro benessere anche fisiologico sia
migliore felici sono attesi nei pensieri
dei piccoli comportamenti alle reazioni
episodi che nel corpo ma in realtà una
delle cose più importante della stagion
e la capacità di poter apprendere dal
sistema di intelligenza e una casa
intelligente non si lascia vincere vuol
dire che dobbiamo impegnarci a
sfruttarlo nella maniera di vivere
questa questa tecnologia ci dirà che noi
abbiamo consumatori chiude un'altra casa
quindi la prossima settimana dobbiamo
stare attenti a un certo settore che in
giro dalla nostra casa il nostro
elettrodomestico dovrà esserlo perché
valore diverso
possiamo sapere se siamo nervosi o meno
se consigliamo tanta acqua così abbiamo
bisogno di concentrarci sui consumi
elettrici
tutte queste queste attenzioni in realtà
rappresentano per la conduzione in ha
montato le conseil tecnologica perché
come si che esiste già oggi la potremo
implementare due giorni se potessimo è
una questione semplicemente di capitale
di diciamo di volontà politica
nell'organizzazione malati nelle
tecnologie cisco già quello che deve
cambiare nella mansione assoluto
nell'evoluzione del seno la
consapevolezza e la coscienza di sapere
di essere parte da un sistema anche un
parte di una comunità che il
l'intervento del sequel comportamento
del singolo a una grossa influenza non
sono molte ma anche all'interno della
rete di persone riuscire a far parte di
una nuova società
parole come armonia comunità
partecipazione integrazione diventino
delle regioni non dipende da un ente
esterno da un governo che ci
incontreremo
dipende da lui come modificato dal
mercato i nostri acquisti come noi
modificato il sistema generativo per
nostri consumi quindi a voi che io
lascio la palla per riuscire a cambiare
questo mondo così come io lo faccio ogni
giorno e vi lascio con una citazione che
uno dei miei riferimenti nella vita ma
magari è una frase bellissima dovesse
riportare il giorno che si doveva vedere
in questo modo quindi un modo per
sottolineare ancora che vivevano del
singolo in quest'anno in questa
relazione